this is ejo underground podcast number
91 sitting here with Eko Charles chat
GPT
yeah
uh it's coming matter of fact you could
say it's already here so I've been
playing around with Chad GPT see what
the deal is you you've used it for
something yeah what have you used it for
uh plenty so actually I found out a lot
of stuff I don't want to go off on too
much of a thing M but chat GPT turns out
so far in my experience to be a
like an assistant person Who's down to
do all the research you need him to do
forever um what have you researched oh
the last thing I researched was actually
you I said write a script about
XYZ um written by Joo willink how' it do
bad
terrible I've tried that too it's not
it's off yeah it's it it ends up with a
you you get with a caricature that's
what you get caricature of my writing or
of me yeah my personality yeah it was
literally here's the
the put it this then again I know it's
just a state of of like how it is right
now I understand that like literally
like next week it could be better it
actually is better right now yeah but
currently given when I did it a few days
ago whatever it was poor it did a very
poor job very poor job it was using
words that I
literally witnessed you say I would
never use that word and it used that
word do you know what word it is what
Warrior
yeah I mean it's not that I would never
use but there's a there's a very
specific time for that yeah and that's
what I mean when you it's not an often
used word yeah like you I forget the
exact context you said it but it was
under certain circumstances you would
say I would never use the word Warrior
yeah for like for that for
that more than once by the way well I
was uh playing with chat GPT so I asked
it I asked chat GPT what are some flaws
from Joo willink's
principles pretty straightforward it
does a pretty good job it does like a
90% job but here's the problem the 10%
is like real critical yeah it misses
it's like saying hey 90% of the
ingredients for your
your uh steak were correct yeah you know
butter salt pepper steak but it the part
that it the ingredient misses is
steak I it landed on me as a very
generic uh result like a very generic
um like response to your your prompts
that's so so I asked at this prompt what
are some flaws from Joo willink's
principles and it said this Jo willink
is a former Navy SEAL author and
motivational speaker known for his
disciplined and noons approach to
leadership and personal
development while he has a large
following and is respected by many there
are a few criticisms associated with
him number one it says and it gives
bullet that Chad GPT really likes bullet
points and
lists it say the first one it says
aggressive and militaristic approach
some critics argue that willing
leadership philosophy and communication
style can be overly aggressive or
militaristic his emphasis on Extreme
ownership and discipline may not
resonate with everyone as it can be
perceived as rigid or unyielding in
certain
contexts so I actually agree with that
that that perception cuz what does it
call it it
says critics well actually I guess it's
this is what's my fault it's my fault
because that's what kind of what I look
like yeah you know what I mean like I
look like that I look like aggressive
and militaristic yeah anybody that
spends any time actually going into the
principles themselves will realize that
it's the opposite of rigid in fact open
keeping an open mind is one of the key
components humility is one of the key
components listening to what other
people have to say all these things are
ke you've been you've heard me talk
about this stuff for years so rigid and
unyielding are actually the opposite of
the way I have always LED yeah so now I
get where it comes from because I also
wrote a book called discipline equals
Freedom so they take that one thing and
extrapolate it out to be an unyielding
form I mean anybody well I was going to
say anybody that's ever worked for me I
wouldn't I don't know if you work for me
but you've definitely worked with me for
how long 7 years s years yeah officially
how how rigid and un yielding would you
say my leadership style is not rigid and
not unyielding I'll tell you so there
you go so out of the gate uh what would
you give them for a grade on that on
that statement well it's hard to
determine what they actually mean
because at face value zero or or what do
you say one to 10 I give him a I give
him a one I would say one and this
really just reflects of like what you
guys talk about um where you're like
default aggressive right that's
literally saying you have a shirt about
it default aggressive so Chad GPT is
going to pick that up and be like well
some people don't like that aggression
they don't like that whatever but then
the little caveat which is very
important by the way it's actually
bigger than a caveat it's like kind of
the key component is aggressive isn't
towards people it's towards make it's
towards making things happen and then
you're like oh hold there's only one
person you got to hold your uh yourself
accountable not others accountable so
like accountability right big I'm big on
accountability kind of a thing but for
myself at me exactly right so all right
they get a 1.5 so well you give them a
one we'll just give them a one one sure
okay so they get a one on that one next
one is lack of nuance willink's messages
and advice often emphasize personal
responsibility and discipline which some
critics argue can Overlook systemic or
external factors that influence outcomes
they argue that his approach it's weird
that there's the they right some critics
quote and they like I've never seen this
stuff before but it captures it they
argue that his approach may not
adequately address the complexities of
certain situations or the impact of
factors beyond an individual's
control again I think all this stuff is
is my fault because the surface kind of
image or the surface impression that
you're going to get from the title of
the books right extreme
ownership discipline equals Freedom
leadership strategy and tactics all
those books kind of imply this sort of
thing so at a surf his value I can see
where chat gbt is going to going to miss
out here uh
because look I've been we've been doing
a podcast we have hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of hours talking about the
Nuance of leadership and how it applies
to all these different situations so and
that's critical yeah so lack of
nuance uh what do you give them for a
grade on this one it can we give zeros
yeah you can give a zero okay I give
zero this is why because literally your
second book is called the dichotomy of
leadership so it's
like good point hey that's a good point
so lack of nuance is literally like
against if someone's like there's no
Nuance that's literally the opposite of
what you're saying yeah that's
interesting I mean I'm just I just
pulled out the book dichotomy of
leadership and the inside flap says
dichotomy provides the crucial insight
and awareness necessary for leaders to
understand when to lead and when to
follow when to focus and when to detach
when to tighten the Reign and when to
let the team run when to aggressively
maneuver and when to be prudent like
it's it's literal Nuance y that's what
it's about the only I can't for me
giving them a zero would mean they
there's no basis in what they're saying
yeah I have to give chat GPT at least
the credit
of understanding what exists yeah in
some way yeah I'll give him a one okay
can we can we round it up to a one that
you make a good point with like zero
basis so like basically you got
what is chat GPT hanging on to to result
in this answer or what they latch on to
it latch on to um maybe it is
100% on you kind of a thing right where
it's like yes which is what's
interesting about that is when it talks
about uh they argue that his approach
may not adequately address the
complexities of certain situations or
the impact of factors beyond an
individual's control so how one of the
earliest questions I got asked about
this topic was someone said hey you know
my daughter has terminal cancer how do I
take ownership of that and I said hey
you can't take ownership of that what
you can take ownership of is how you
respond to it and there you go so this
is actually addressing what is in this
and it's in I've said that a thousand
times written it so I'll give them a one
that they knew that it's a topic but
that's about it next up simplistic
Solutions some detractors argue that
willing Solutions and strategies May
oversimplify complex
problems that's the point by the
way while his emphasis on taking
ownership and developing discipline it's
obviously this thing is everything talks
about responsibility and
discipline and ownership which is kind
of like me I guess Al so it's kind of
getting at least a one developing
discipline can be valuable critics
contend that they may not address the
root C causes of issues or consider the
broader context in which they
arise so over
simplifying maybe you're just okay this
is one of those things where again wrote
a book called leadership strategy and
tactics we talk all the time about the
fact that you can't just win the
Tactical battle that's right in front of
you you need to find out the long-term
solution you need to find out where the
problem is coming
from that's where you need to f Fus your
efforts I I'm giving this a one yeah I
and I'm assuming I understand what chat
GPT is talking about but I actually will
give it a what did you say 1 to 10 yeah
1 to 10 I'll give it a five five okay
how come you give me a five because and
this is just hanging on to that idea of
oversimplifying it because
sometimes this is less about your
philosophy though this is more about you
as a human like actual existing human
being where certain things I think you
overlook as
being like normal things you overlook it
like just cuz you're you and you're like
oh dang you probably never really
thought about that that certain things
that much I bet that you're
just wrong maybe maybe that's just my
let me give you the example the example
is how do I get out of bed in the
morning right this is what you're
thinking how do I get out of bed in the
morning oh you want to get out of the
bed in the morning set your alarm clock
when it goes off get out of bed yeah
period yeah that's the right answer dude
yeah I know you can say that there's a
bunch of little mitigating circumstances
but the fact of the matter is if you
want to get out of bed in the morning
shut your alarm get out of bed in the
morning yeah well your your five just
went back down to a one you're actually
wrong still at five in fact you're
pushing 5.5 right now so here cuz this
is this is why so here's the analogy
where like it's like if if two people
were yelling in your ear right yelling
in your and you just said yeah just
ignore them where it's like cool yes in
theory or in a vacuum sure someone could
find it you could probably ignore them
but the normal person the norm they
can't ignore them like it's you can't
ignore them it's too loud it's too close
to your ear you can feel the warmth of
their breath like there's so much so
many things that B that I think anyway I
don't know I can't read your mind but
there's certain things that affect
certain people in certain ways that
don't affect you in certain ways and I
feel so I'm not human now I feel
false tonomy I feel like you just assume
a lot of the time not all the time but
maybe more times than you realize that
certain things are literally like normal
this is normal thing for everybody I
think I got asked this on Twitter
maybe I'm almost positive I asked this
on Twitter and I responded the question
was like hey what do you do when you're
because you know how a lot of times when
I'm doing Twitter I'm traveling and so
someone wrote like hey what do you do
when you're on a flight and the person
behind you
it keeps kicking your chair or the
there's a baby behind you
screaming and hitting your chair while
you're on the flight what do you do and
I wrote write I wrote I write three
chapters for my next book yeah like this
is no factor to me like literally no
Factor so when you talk about people
screaming in your ears and what there's
some people that have some kind of a
medical trigger that goes off when they
get yelled at no it's it's not true like
you're not you're not that's not that's
not true if if Captain Plum can be in a
prison cell in Hanoi and and take
ownership of being annoyed with his
cellmates I think you can take a little
ownership if someone's annoying you by
being loud right yeah and see now you're
going like with these kind of absolutes
um where you take this extreme situation
like probably one of the most extreme
situations ever and you compare that to
Everyday person and be like look like
what the hell you know but but but isn't
there some validity to that because if a
human human being can be locked in a
prison cell in a prisoner of war camp
yeah and decide that he's going to take
ownership of things that are really
truly bothering him yeah in an area
where he's trapped yeah then someone's
talking on a plane or yelling on a plane
and you're going to let that drive you
crazy where you want to lash out like is
that where we're at uh well in real life
yes because that extreme situation does
that's a very extreme situation and in
certain situations yeah a baby crying is
I probably not even hear that in certain
situations especially the more extreme
the situation so again like you it's
comes down to simplifying it like that
where it's like you're taking something
like literally a million steps down the
road and you're saying it's the same as
step number one and two it's different
it's there's more to it than that is
what I'm saying and I'm not saying it's
bad or good and in fact in the how youer
is f that's how everyone operates that's
the whole point there's so much mistake
the mistake is saying instead of saying
ho I want to write a book people say oh
yeah how do I write a book I say write
thousand words a day takes one hour find
that one hour write a th words a day
people act like that's the craziest
thing they've ever heard people want to
get up in the morning oh you don't you
do set your alarm clock oh people want
to you they're having trouble working
out every day cool you know what I do go
work out every day yeah and I'm these
are not I think I think you're actually
you actually could be wrong here you're
over complicating things because that's
human nature that's why Simplicity is
such a powerful tool yes but yes and I
agree with that I mean sure could we sit
here and say there's all these different
mitigating circumstances that have
unfold when someone the alarm clock goes
off and they were up late last night and
their circadian rhythms off and they
want to wake up their wife and they
actually were feeling a little bit
sniffly in the when they their their
nose was a little bunged up as they
slept and there's like a bunch of things
right a bunch of reasons and proba you
need more rest and you know uh uh the
the podcast told me that sleep was the
most important thing for longevity like
all these things right there's all these
things sure yeah they can all they can
all keep you in bed yeah pillow feel
pillow feels good yeah yeah I get it War
blanket feels good right and it's less
about any specific thing what I'm saying
is you as a human being not you're the
thing is you're right about the thing
like I said from the begin like your
approach to it is correct just a little
oversimplified to a level of five out of
10 so I'm saying so again this is like
you personally so you know what for the
sake of
we're going to go with five we're going
to go with with your complete we're
going full credit we're get it five cuz
everything's super complex and get no no
no that's not what I'm saying that's not
what I'm saying at all see see how
you're oversimplifying the thing again
so so you got look do you know what you
know what tolerance is right do you
believe or do you do you know or believe
you I don't know maybe you don't believe
this that different people have
different levels of Tolerance like
actual tolerance Toler for what anything
just anything yeah different people have
different levels of Tolerance exactly
right so even just that alone would
would make things clear that it's not
just like hey no you just do it or hey
no just ignore them we're like just just
the individual Nuance of Tolerance it in
and of itself makes it not that simple
the approach is the approach is the same
okay like hey let's work towards this
let's work towards that here's here's I
think where the where the mistake kind
of comes in real life when people will
be like hey everyone's different hey
it's easier for Joo because he has high
tolerance for this stuff or whatever
therefore it's okay for me to slack it's
like that when they when they come when
someone comes to that conclusion and I'm
not excluding myself either when they
come to that conclusion and use it as
like a crutch there's where the problems
well that's definitely a problem so I
understand the usefulness of your
simplistic approach okay so that's a
good point and we'll give it a five and
for those of you that want to believe
the echo Charles system of complexity
and everything's a lot harder and it
makes a lot more difference and
everyone's different there's always
injac I'm some kind of a freaking robot
cyborg
over that is a little excerpt of what we
are doing on the Joo underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Joo underground.com And subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 a month and if you can afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground